[Music]
So when we do the poku game and he's
trying Okay, you see how he come over?
So let's look at what he did. I push.
I'm trying to bring it in. He came over
the top. You see that? Okay. So he goes
over the top and I go up.
Okay. So again, I'm trying to bring him
this way. He came over the top. Drop the
elbow and you're on the inside. You have
the other hand working the entire time.
So maybe I was going to go this way. You
see,
he counter over the top and I have to go
and I have to go the other way. So,
we're focus on this hand again. I'm
here. I'm going here. Goes over the top
and around. what my elbows are doing.
That's the elbows are the are the key.
So elbow, he go he's going over the top.
Elbow,
I'm down the inside. So with our
spirals, I went inward spiral. He's
going over the top. I go outward spiral.
Okay, which elbow went
up and in the outer spiral. It goes down
and it's going out. Okay.
So, we'll work on that one. You came in.
I went one. You'll feel that I go pay
attention that I keep the eye on my
body. So, I'm not going to stay here
because all this is getting closer to
me. So, as as I reach for him, you see
the angle of my torso. He's going over
the top and I work that angle. There is
also a deviation angle. So I'm not going
straight back. I go around the energy.
You see that? So I
so I keep the kata space between my
torso and elbow. Okay, let's try. If we
look at what he did, we got to get a
little slip. He's coming in. You see
that?
So, which spiral is he doing?
>> Okay. So, I'm going inward. He's going
to go outward. I go outward. And there
we go. Okay. You guys see that?
>> Okay. So, I was trying to go in. He goes
outward. I go outward. And there I go.
Just like the swords,
watch how our elbows are working
together,
not behind. Otherwise, it's going to get
crunched on me. And I have to do more.
So, I feel
[Music]
okay. He never presses on me, but I
can't take it all the way off or I'll
lose what?
>> The adhesion. Okay. try to we first
reach and I came here you see and I am
trying to do this one.
So we go he counters it and know how I
got to take it the other way.
So, we're going to look at his hand.
Okay. So, just so we'll do it slow so I
can talk. Okay. So, one I'm trying to go
there. Goes here. And now this one goes
there.
You guys see that?
>> Okay. So, it was trying to get here.
And this one's going here. So, I'm on
the I'm on the uh inside outside. Got
it? And then I'm on the other side of my
angles of deflection. You see that?
Okay. But if he gets over the top of
this, there's the touch right there.
Okay. So, when you feel that, that's
where I now got to go the other way.
So, now we going in. Okay. Well, let me
start. Okay. Just do your first thing
and you'll find. Okay, there it is right
there. So, there I go. I was
>> trying to get to the inside. Do you guys
understand?
>> Okay, but once I realize I'm now going
to be on the inside of this one, I go to
the outside of this one. Okay.
>> So, I'm going here, right? He's getting
to the inside and I go to the outside.
And you have to make sure when you're
here,
as this hand comes back, you can't be in
the way. You have to move out of the
way.
Okay. And refine your circle.
Here we go. Boom. Boom.
and use the X pattern. So, as we're
going here, boom, I did a different one.
Okay,
>> this one's going to go here. And once
you have that, this one goes that way.
Do it again.
Okay, try it.
So, what what we're what we're doing
here is I'm I'm harmonizing things.
Okay.
So, I'm on the inside outside. You see
that? As opposed to on the outside, two
on the inside. So, yeah, I I started
there, but then I harmonized. And when I
harmonize, that's where you get the
yield. The yield that he goes to 4 A,
that sets up the X pattern. Okay? So, if
I say on the outside as we did, you're
going to you're going to hit that line,
but we're not doing that. I want you to
play with the four and eight. So, we
have to figure out how to yield and how
to keep contact. Okay? So I start here
and I go I'm going here. You take So you
take him here and then that's the
projection. Okay. But as we're going
there, he counters that one. So now we
got to go this way.
All I got to do is get on the outside.
So I've actually done three different
ways of getting on the outside. Okay. So
when I go here and he counters, right,
you can go here. I saw some of you saw
you do that. Some of you are fine. Just
end here. And there you have it. Time to
do the other one that first came to me,
which is the one where I came around
this way.
You guys see that? So, the first one I
went here and found it. On the other
one, I came here and I found it this
way.
Okay. What I don't want to do though is
when I go here and I get on the inside
because here's where you're going to
stop. You're going to stop him. Even if
you're pushing him around, you see that
you're you're technically you're
stopping. So you want to be on the
inside
on the
on the outside. I mean, okay, that will
also be consistent that my angle of
deflection is going
to the right, my right, and my body went
to my left, he went to my right. Okay,
so don't do I know it's there, but he's
not really there. Okay, the two insides.
track.